russia's energy giant gas prom says it
will be reducing daily gas deliveries
via the north stream pipeline to germany
due to the repair of compressor units
supplied by german company siemens gas
prom plans to supply up to 100 million
cubic meters per day that's according to
an official company's statement the
pipeline's capacity stands at 167
million cubic meters north stream is the
older one of two parallel pipelines
leading from russia to germany newest
north stream 2 was finished recently but
isn't used under sanctions against
russia over its war in ukraine
well for more on that i'm not joining
the studio here by chris kobach from gw
business uh chris what's behind this
well you just mentioned it uh there um
according to gaspron the reduction is
necessary because of the repair of
compressor units by siemens company many
of us know
i'm sure
um and apparently there was some delay
in getting these compressors back from
siemens we have to understand that
siemens along with other many western
companies uh
went out of the russian market
after
moscow's uh invasion of of ukraine um so
there might have been uh some difficulty
there in actually repairing um these
units now that is the official statement
of gas problem of course it comes at a
time
when russia has cut gas deliveries to
numerous european nations among them
finland the netherlands uh and and
poland and it comes at a time when
russia uh when ukraine rather
temporarily halted the transit of
russian gas bound for europe uh amidst
the fighting in the luhansk region now
uh what does it mean on the receiving
end germany being very very dependent on
on russian gas it might not have
that big of an impact currently because
uh summer's just around the corner in
europe we are well out of the heating
season
but it could make
it more difficulty filling the necessary
reserves for when temperatures are
dropping again in fall and in winter and
that has been one of the decisive issues
here when it comes to the question of
how germany can transition away from its
dependence on russia when it comes to uh
fossil fuels and energy the question
being will people freeze in winter times
and obviously politicians are trying
everything to avoid that so uh having
less gas now
might make it more challenging to fill
up these reserves currently uh germany
is is quite on track and filling these
resources but again it can be it could
could be more difficult should this turn
out not to be a short time problem but
maybe something different something more
long-lasting i guess we'll find out in
the winter chris corbett the dw business
thank you chris
well let's cross over to our chief
political editor michaela coofner hi
michelle good to see you now what's
behind this decision by gazprom to limit
supplies
well gazprom says it's not its uh
decision that this is due to maintenance
work that was
needed on that pipeline that supplies
most of german
gas directly through the north stream
one pipeline compressor units are being
serviced by siemens we understand that
they are actually ready for replacement
and the big question now is
why they have been unable to be
delivered back and whether the timing of
this maintenance is earlier than due
that was expected this summer although
it's not possible at this point in time
to really
find out whether it is the russian side
that is deliberately limiting or whether
it really is the european side that is
dragging its heels in terms of
delivering the equipment the hardware
required to keep the pipeline running at
this moment in time but it's a highly
sensitive issue as europe is trying to
store up its gas storage ahead of what
could be another long autumn or winter
well that brings me on to my my next
question michaela does it mean that
we'll soon see natural gas shortages
here in germany and perhaps in the rest
of europe
that's an issue that is looming for now
we're hearing that nobody's
seen any drops yet and that there is
monitoring going on and in parallel
we've seen the german government
announce that it is
not just continuing its effective
control of gas from garmanya which is
holds major gas infrastructure
particularly storage infrastructure and
pipeline infrastructure here in germany
but that the german government is also
going to grant
gas prong garmanya and a
billion euro loan to keep it afloat and
to keep it from going
into insolvency
also it will be renamed
into energy for europe energy security
for europe so clearly this is also a
information war in the making here a
proper gander pr
point scored there by the german side
against of what is effectively still a
russian-owned company here in germany
dw's chief political editor mikhail
kufner thank you